I think they obviously made a terrible
mistake because they had presumed that
if they were to have that referendum
that it would be a closed issues very
quickly and that the political problems
that they had internally as a
consequence of the minority that they
thought would be pushed aside they were
mistaken Prime Minister has lost his job
shamon is obviously going to lose their
job
it's a terrible outcome in all respect
it didn't have to happen
I always thought that the real problem
in Europe was the Euro which I've always
thought was basically an unstable
currency can't exist permanently an
existing structure it never entered my
mind that sterling was an issue that's
it's a floating currency and the
Brittany is or she was in fairly good
shape economically if your attention is
on Europe
what would you request from Chancellor
Merkel and what would you request from
Brussels well I'm not in the position to
request that we'd like to know now I
think what is let me start off what I
think ought to happen with respect to
the euro first of all the euro was being
pulled apart basically by the continued
existence of grace Greece in the in the
euro structure least got in by mistake
or should say miscalculation of some of
the data they submitted for purposes of
entering the euro if we can very clear
when the next government Greece Greek
government showed up that the data which
had been submitted were just not
accurate they have been a thorn in the
side of the whole euro structure ever
since then they should never have been
the arrow they should get out as soon as
possible if you want to sustain
fundamental euro structure the
difficulty of the euro is one we were
all aware of very early on I sat in on
the early stages of the development of
the new currency right before they had
the name euro the basic purpose was
essentially to foster the question of
European integration politically not
right certainly in other words